i mean how do you explain this to other
youth
how do you make them understand
when most of us
really can't understand
the callousness of these people who fire
people without careful lives it's just
senselessness
[Music]
hello my name is pastor corey brooks and
i'm still here can you believe it on the
south side of chicago living out of this
tent for 100 days from november 20th to
february 28th bringing attention and
awareness to the gun violence in chicago
but most of all i'm staying here to
raise money to build a community center
in a community that is really needed
this block called oh block it's named
after a young man who was killed
by the name of od perry the gangs
picked up his name and called it odot we
decided we're going to keep the o but
we're going to change it from od purity
to opportunity block
so that's the reason why i'm thankful to
fox for giving you this opportunity
every day to give you rooftop
revelations just some thoughts some
solutions some
ideas that i think about very often
well this morning i woke up
to a sun times article and it was a
photo of a coffin and some horrific
numbers with it
numbers that hit right at home
i know people in these numbers and they
were
not just numbers to me
chicago has lost 57 school-aged children
to gun violence this year can you
believe that
16 of them in elementary middle school
according to records
maintained by the sun times in 2020 49
kids were killed two of them before they
reached high school dozens more 18 year
olds who were either current or recent
students were fatally shot
they're just
reverberating in their school
communities
then there are these kids who are
injured in shootings but survive like
the phillips academy high school student
who along with the security guard was
struck by gunfire
as she walked out of the building
just this far
two victims mentioned in the article a
mother and a son
i know them
i did the funeral
i don't know about you
but the feeling i got from reading all
about these kids
killed
your senselessness
just how senseless
this all is
i mean how do you explain this to other
youth
how do you make them understand when
most of us
really can't understand
the callousness of these people who fire
people without careful lives it's just
senselessness
we cannot get into the senselessness we
cannot become love we must transform the
pain into positive we must see the
purpose
it's all we can do
with our human nature to make things
better
the bible teaches us that children are
inheritors of god a blessing
and this is why our
feeling of a community center is so
important
it's so vital to what we're attempting
to do to give kids a space a safe space
a place
where they can grow a place where they
can learn a place where they can get
affirmation attention and acceptance
to erase the senselessness
that's terrorizing the community
by replacing it with a positive force
we need
help in chicago
our young people deserve a fighting
chance
i'm so thankful to fox giving me this
platform
to talk about issues that are so dear to
my heart
to bring you along on the journey as we
talk about violence
so that you can understand
that all of these children being shot
and killed
senseless
as i always say
thank you for sharing with me these
rooftop revelations
and i'll see you tomorrow
peace
you